big first
really really big first the first openly
transgender figure skater
has just appeared at the European figure
skating championships in espu Finland
this is
a Finnish skater who's
an older man
dressed up as a woman skating around not
not the most gracefully but he's sort of
skating and then he falls down and then
he falls on the ice and
he can't stand up
and so then
The Finnish people with the flag come
out and try to help him stand up
and then
and the craziest part of this whole
display
is that we're not allowed to acknowledge
it I mean on this show we do but in the
culture you're not if you if you're
sitting there
in that audience I
you can't hear it on any of the clips
that I've seen and I'm sure you couldn't
hear it in the in the audience
you're not allowed to say oh this is
weird this is funny this is obviously
absurd no we all have to just sit there
and pretend oh yes she's so beautiful
these poor little girls who are on the
track teams with all the confused men
are on the pen swimming team with that
Hulk of a man who took all their
trophies and then what do the girls have
to do
on camera they have to smile they have
to plaster his mom and say this is a
really great she is so beautiful we love
being on her team and then privately of
course when they're speaking to
journalists and they can remain
anonymous they say this is terrible we
don't want some guy getting naked in our
locker room and taking her trophies and
taking her scholarships and this is
deeply unjust but then when the cameras
come out they say aha well this is you
are beautiful Caitlyn and Dylan though I
don't know what Dylan's new lady name is
going to be I guess Dylan's kind of
androgynous you are a beautiful Nina
Maria finish you're the greatest skater
I've ever seen you're a regular Tanya
Harding
yeah
in totalitarian countries
one of the things that we Marvel at
is that the people are forced to perform
lies all the time when Kim Jong-il died
and you had major parades all throughout
North Korea to honor the death of the
great leader
you saw those cameras in all these North
Koreans
perhaps some were moved seriously by
sympathy I kind of doubt a lot of it
though for many of them they were
performing it because there were guns
pointed at them and they they knew that
if they didn't cry enough over the death
of dear leader
they could be tortured they could be
killed
their family could be killed
everybody has to lie this is true in
Stalin's Russia
and Soviet Union this is true in China
and this is now true
in the West
we are forced to lie too because our
government is increasingly totalitarian
it's a total state
it comprises everything
if you in your HR meeting
don't affirm that some hulking hairy
dude wearing a dress and stilettos and
with lipstick smeared on his face is
actually a beautiful woman you could be
fired and you probably will be fired and
once you're fired for that you you're
gonna have a hard time getting more
employment
and you're going to be a pariah in your
Society
it was so terrible when North Korea does
that terrible and so the good thing we
live in America the land of the free and
the home of totalitarian delusion every
day more and more so
[Music]
but love is love right love is love you
do you
trans women are women
everybody's uh whatever they want to be
okay if love is love then I've got a
question about a story that just came
out right now text Knowles to 98 98 98
the current administration's New Year's
goals are to tax spend and turn a blind
eye to inflation if this is at odds with
your goals you're tired of the
government playing games with your
savings and your retirement plan then
you need to get in touch with the
experts at Birch gold today for over
five thousand years gold has withstood
inflation geopolitical turmoil stock
market crashes now you can own gold and
attack sheltered retirement account
Birch gold makes it easy to convert an
IRA or 401K into an IRA in Precious
Metals text nulls scanner wlas 298 9898
to claim your free info kit on gold and
then talk to one of their precious
metals Specialists with an A plus rating
With Better Business Bureau thousands of
happy customers and countless five-star
reviews you can trust Birch gold to help
protect your savings text Knowles Canada
be Les to 98 9898 and protect yourself
with gold today that is Knowles Canada
w-les to 98 98 98
today you'll thank me later
story out of ABC News
a couple of hosts for Good Morning
America 3. we're just fired because they
had an affair
Amy robach and TJ Holmes I've never
watched this show I didn't know there
was such a thing as Good Morning America
3 but they were hosts of it and they
just got fired because they were both
married
and then they had a consensual Affair
and then this came to light and and it's
not as though one person accused the
other of sexual harassment or anything
like that
they're both married
but they had a consensual Affair and uh
now they're now they're canned
why is that wrong
I know why it's wrong
because marriage is an indissoluble bond
between a husband and a wife
for the good of the spouse is in the
sake of the generation and education of
children I know I know that it's wrong
because spouses take a vow before God
and before the political Community to to
remain with one another through thick
and thin good times and bad sickness and
health
and and that's wrong but
that's not what the modern culture
believes the modern culture believes
that marriage is nothing but a kind of
meaningless sheet of paper and we can
leave our spouses for whatever reason we
want and that's called a no-fault
divorce and there's nothing wrong with
polyamory polygamy whatever there's
nothing wrong with any of these
Arrangements
Love Is Love
Love Is Love that's the whole argument
for redefining marriage is that the
affection between two men and the
affection between two women is the same
as marriage the affection and then
institution that that desire leads
toward
uh
in the institution of marriage that's
all the same okay well if love is love
if all shades of love and affection are
exactly the same then why don't they get
to have their that was consensual
yeah it wasn't so nice to their spouses
but so what we don't we don't really
give much
Credence to marriage vows anymore
why is this wrong
because if if we know that this is wrong
then what we're really saying is that TJ
Holmes and Amy Robuck should have
repressed their romantic desire for each
other they should have denied the love
that they felt for one another they
should have pushed it way way deep down
because they had other obligations
because the moral order demanded more of
them then that they follow their love
for one another to its
physical conclusion
but if that's the case then
and isn't that then isn't that just the
case then isn't that just how it is and
shouldn't we apply that to all other
all sorts of other manner of love as
well
no a little bit confusing
Love Is Love except for Amy Amy robach
and TJ Holmes they don't get to have
their love but
all sorts of other people all sorts of
weird polyamorous people with three guys
and two women and a billy goat that's
fine that's love that's wonderful how
dare you judge that but
Amy roback and TJ Holmes get fired for a
consensual Affair that's really weird
it's also really weird because Amy
robach I actually had forgotten this
until producer Danny reminded me of this
today
Amy robach
you may have heard of her because she
was caught on a hidden mic
discussing how she wanted to pursue the
Jeffrey Epstein story at ABC and the
producers and the executives shut her
down and she knew that Jeffrey Epstein
was a real story
when she knew that this involved a lot
of corruption she wanted to run the
story and the higher ups at the network
said nope don't talk about that
so it adds another layer to this where I
think huh it's so so weird how people
who transgress the
powerful liberal Elites people people
who contradict them or who get on the
wrong side of them
they end up in a sex scandal and their
career goes away and then they bury them
not all that long after they raise these
problems really weird not obviously what
they did is terribly wrong and they
should repent of it and go to confession
and try to make up with their spouses
and try to keep their families together
there's a lot more to this story though
seems like there's a lot more to this
story both as a cultural matter
and even as a particular political
matter
with regard to Mr Epstein who may or
probably did not kill himself
then meets the eye if you are not a
daily wire member what is wrong with you
head on over dailywire.com Knowles use
promo code Knowles at checkout yet two
months free on all annual plans and I
will get to chat with you in the member
block
[Music]
foreign